[Music]
this morning we're getting an exclusive
first look at the future of
high-speed rail travel in particular
amtrak's new
faster acela last summer we showed you
the facility in new york state where the
trains will be built
pretty cool now we're finding out what
the trains can do on the tracks and how
the pandemic
is affecting the testing the rollout
continues despite
word from amtrak that 2400 more
employees face possible layoffs
and that's in addition to furloughs
affecting 2 000 employees
that started last week chris van cleave
visited the colorado facility
where the testing is taking place
[Music]
that is the sound of speed next year
america's fastest train will start
rolling down the tracks between boston
new york and washington
at up to 160 miles an hour we're getting
a first look at the newest cella as it
undergoes
speed testing at this sprawling 30
thousand acre facility outside pueblo
colorado
it's going to be a game changer amtrak
vice president caroline decker
why can't the u.s have as fast to trains
as other countries
in europe and in asia you have a lot of
infrastructure
a lot of right-of-ways that were built
specifically
for these designated high-speed
corridors the northeast corridor
which in many areas is more than 100
years old was never designed for
high-speed trains
the new trains will be 10 miles an hour
faster than the current 20-year-old
speed fleet amtrak hopes to shave about
15 minutes off a trip between
dc and boston while carrying 25 percent
more passengers
and using 20 percent less energy
during its year of certification testing
here at the transportation technology
center
this train is basically a rolling test
lab we look at
speed upgrades we look at tilt testing
we look at all of the safety appliances
that are on the train set
and we just make sure everything is
operating like it's supposed to be
built by alstom in hornell new york the
new acela is part of a 2.4 billion
dollar modernization effort
that is continuing despite the pandemic
and amtrak's decision to furlough or lay
off more than 2 000 employees
given the pandemic given the plummeting
demand why move forward with this
project now
we have to look to the future we owe it
to the generations of americans that are
here
10 years 20 years from now when no doubt
train travel will play a huge role in
terms of mobility for our country
even as the newest sella is racing down
this test track at speeds up to 165
miles an hour the coronavirus
is forcing some redesigns on the inside
of the train
we are improving some of the design
looking at air conditioning airflow
so you're going to go in and change
perhaps the air filter and the airflow
in the train
there is some design activity ongoing to
do that it's airflows it's touchless
it's installing sanitizing stations
it's all those things the train meets
stronger crash worthiness standards
while promising a smoother ride
on the inside it boasts improved wi-fi
and a host of contactless features
including a self-service cafe car
and a touchless restroom for cbs this
morning chris van cleave
pueblo colorado touchless it's a it's a
touchless restaurant how does that how
does that work i think you touch
yourself but you don't touch anything
right how does that work something we'll
find out
i'm not going to get graphic you all
know what i'm talking about it doesn't
raise some questions yeah i did like
what carolyn decker said where she said
you know we have to look to the future
yes yeah
it was a great question question from
quiz and i love your response we have to
look to the future because
there is a future here i can't wait to
get on it yeah in the year 2022 and yeah
and saving those 15 minutes on the way
to boston that adds up
i just hope they improve the tracks
along with improving the trains the
problem was always the trains were good
but the tracks were terrible